- The kids at school said the Steelers aren’t for real.
- The Steelers are real…if you believe.
- I don’t think this movie ends well, man.
- Did you beat the Chiefs but almost lose to the Jets?
- [Together:] Uh-huh.
- That seems pretty specific, man.
- [Joe Buck:] INTRODUCING: THE 7TH SEED.
NOW EVEN BAD TEAMS CAN MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
- Can we get it, Coach?
- [Together:] PLEASE?
- Ehhhh.
- I WANT IT, I WANT IT, I WANT IT, I—
- I’m here to get one of these fancy seventh seeds—
- THERE’S ONLY ONE FLUFFING AVAILABLE, AND DADGUMMIT, MY KIDS GET IT.
- Oof! Spider 2 Whyyyyy, man?
- [Announcer:] REMINDER: THE 7TH SEED IS ALSO AVAILABLE IN NFC!
- Vikings  don't want it.
- Uh, yeah, maybe.
- [T.Y. Hilton:] Phil! Over here!
- Tough friggin’ play…
JACOBY!
- ♪♪♪ IT’S BEGINNING TO LOOK A LOT LIKE BIG TRUZZ... ♪♪♪
AHHH!
- This is what my kid deserves.
- Thanks, Dad.
- Not you.
- Aaron Donald hurts more than a pillow fight!
- Be careful. It’s a choking hazard.
- ♪♪♪ SANTA GRUDEN, TIME FOR ME TO ESTABLISH THE RUN, FOR FUN! ♪♪♪
- YOU DON’T FLUFFIN' CROSS THIS RIVER.
- Man, get off. That's my turkey hole, man!
- I’ll spice up your stew!
- Wooo! All right, now I gotta get a present for my 61 other kids.
- Shhhhh.
- HELP! HELP! THERE’S A STRANGE STEEL WORKER IN MY HOUSE!
- NO, NO, NO! I'M STEELY MCBEAM, I'M YOUR MASCOT.
- GET HIM, TJ WATT.
- OWW. OW IT HURTS. CHRISTMAS IS RUINED.